now we begin in the united states where
joe biden is
hours away from becoming the 46th
president
he'll lead a country devastated by an
unprecedented health and economic crisis
but in the final hours of his presidency
outgoing president donald trump
has issued more than 140 pardons and
commutations
they include former aide steve bannon
along with rappers little wayne kodak
black
and a former mayor of detroit well
earlier he delivered his farewell
speech to the nation outlining his
legacy
we restored american strength at home
and american leadership abroad
the world respects us again we built the
greatest political movement in the
history of our country
we also built the greatest economy in
the history of the world
we revitalized our alliances and rallied
the nations of the world to stand up to
china like never before
as a result of our bold diplomacy and
principled realism
we achieved a series of historic peace
deals in the middle east
nobody believed it could happen it is
the dawn of a new middle east
and we are bringing our soldiers home i
am especially proud to be the first
president in decades
who has started no new wars
on the night before they take office
biden and vice president-elect
kamala harris paid tribute to more than
400 000 americans who've died of covid19
biden says containing the pandemic is
his number one priority
to heal we must remember
it's hard sometimes to remember
but that's how we heal it's important
to do that as a nation that's why we're
here
today between sundown and dusk
let us shine the lights in the darkness
along the sacred pool of reflection
remember all whom we lost
and it will be an inauguration ceremony
like
none in recent memory downtown
washington dc is virtually a
fortress right now more than 20 000
national guard troops have been deployed
there following this month's attack on
the capital
and threats of more violence
let's go live to natasha for name now
from washington dc natasha
you can't help but notice that this list
of pardons and commutations came out
really in the 11th hour right
absolutely it's not a surprise that this
final spate of pardons by president
trump
includes allies and friends he would not
be the first
president to do that but he has been
criticized already
for the number of people that fell into
that category
most notable of these pardons is former
white house advisor and breitbart editor
of uh breitbart editor steve
bannon this was supposed to be the one
decision
that president trump vacillated there
were
allies making an appeal and even uh
steve bannon has said to have picked up
the phone and had a conversation
with trump on tuesday but there were
also detractors
in the end president trump opted to
pardon
this uh former chief of sorry white
house advisor
and ally of his he hadn't even been
convicted of anything
bannon had been charged though last year
with defrauding supporters who donated
to a private
fund to help build the u.s mexico border
wall
that was of course a very big pet
project of president trump
another notable person who has granted
clemency
is billionaire elliott brody he got
embroiled
in a foreign lobbying case and he pled
guilty last year he was a very prolific
fundraiser for president trump and the
republican
national committee he was set to after
pleading guilty he was set to be
sentenced next month
and then there are others that might uh
be of a surprise to some
they're certainly not household names
two young rappers little wayne
and black kodak uh little wayne
in the run-up to the election vocalizing
his support for president trump
both of them were in trouble for gun
related charges and then you might say
that president trump
crossed partisan lines to issue a pardon
to former democratic
detroit mayor kwame kilpatrick he had
been serving a
28-year federal prison sentence for
extortion
racketeering and bribery but perhaps
what a lot of americans
will be waking up to find out this has
been a big source
of speculation for months is who was not
on that list
and that is president trump his friends
and even his attorney
rudy giuliani there was a lot of
speculation regarding
if president trump would preemptively
try to pardon himself or his family
members
he reportedly sought legal advice and
was told to do so would invite
more trouble because to do so would mean
citing specific crimes
and natasha the the military vehicles
behind you i mean they just
sum up how very different this
inauguration
ceremony atmosphere is going to be
yes the unprecedented presence of
security never
in the united states has there been this
many more than 25 000 national guard and
that does not
include metro police and other law
enforcement agencies
throughout the city this is probably the
fifth or sixth checkpoint we've been to
you see military vehicles and national
guard troops there are fences and
barricades the national mall is closed
the washington monument
very difficult to get around bridges
from virginia to ducey
have been blocked metro stations are
closed
all in an effort to ensure that the city
remains
as locked down as is possible and to
ensure that president-elect joe biden is
safely sworn in
in a matter of hours and we'll be
watching it when it happens thanks so
much
natasha rename there